Joe when you started making intent to
destroy what was the question you were
trying to answer you know for years I've
been fascinated by the Armenian Genocide
and the fact that it's contested history
you know because to me the evidence is
kind of overwhelming and I was actually
approached about making the film and
initially I was not interested in
actually making it because I didn't see
a way to do it that would transcend just
talking heads in archival footage and
then when I heard the promise was being
made I thought that was a real
opportunity to do something different as
a filmmaker but also to really add to
the dialogue that's already out there
about the Armenian Genocide because by
going behind the scenes of the promise
and using that as the present tense
thread it allowed me to make a film
about denial in the aftermath of denial
and the mechanism of denial and that
those are the questions I wanted to
address in this film of course part of
the film is to also tell the underlying
history of the genocide because it's
history that sadly a lot of Americans a
lot of people know all over the world
actually are unfamiliar with because of
the successful attempt to kind of shove
that story under the rug of history but
the ability to actually do it in a way
that's cinematically satisfying so that
we can transcend talking heads and
archival footage by going behind the
scenes of a movie a feature film that
was exciting to me because I wanted to
talk I wanted to talk about the denial
aspect and going behind the scenes of a
big-budget Hollywood movie is not just a
gratuitous device it's central to this
story which is why I thought there was
an opportunity the opportunity to go
behind the scenes of the promise to me
represented a real not just a great
filmmaking device to allow me as a
present tense cinema verite filmmaker
which is one of more comfortable with it
gives me a present tense device to hang
everything on but I knew when I heard
the promise was announced that
it actually represented a historical
moment because over the years
any time Hollywood has attempted to make
a movie that's Armenian Genocide themed
the US State Department gets a complaint
from Turkey they called the Hollywood
studio and they've convinced over the
years Hollywood not not to tackle this
story you know like as early as 1935
Irving Thalberg at MGM was bringing the
book 40 days of Musa Dagh to life to the
screen and in pre-production that movie
was actually shut down because the Turks
complained to the State Department and
the State Department convinced MGM it
wouldn't be in their interest to make
that movie so America has aided and
abetted the denial of this story and one
of the methods that that has happened is
in Hollywood itself where it's been
almost taboo to make big-budget movies
about this incredible historical event
you know America has basically aided and
abetted the denial of the story and one
of the ways they've done it is by
encouraging Hollywood not to tell these
stories you know that would be kind of
like pulling Steven Spielberg aside and
say hey don't make Schindler's List we
need to we need to keep the Germans
happy and that's but that's what's going
on with the Armenian Genocide so you've
never seen you know a big budget or even
a small budget Hollywood you've seen
other filmmakers outside of the US
studio system tackle this but you've
never seen a mainstream Hollywood movie
about their meanie and genocides and
when I heard the promise was being made
which is not a which didn't come from a
studio it's still private money but it
was involving a lot of Hollywood players
Christian Bale Oscar Isaac from you know
the acting standpoint Mike Medavoy you
know major Hollywood producer involve
Ralph winter when I saw that this film
was being made I thought to myself and
then pitched the producers of the
promise that allowing me on set would be
an amazing device both cinematically for
me to tell a present tense unfolding
story to then hang all the history on
which to me just as a filmmaker is a
more interesting way to tell
historical story but it's also that
story is very much connected to the
story of denial because movies have been
repressed when atom egoyan as you see in
the film in Canada even made our Arad
which is an Armenian Genocide themed
film he received threats to not make the
film so there have been all sorts of
examples where artists have been you
know threatened or encouraged not to
make their films and Hollywood itself
has just avoided this subject so for me
as a filmmaker when I heard the promise
was being made it felt like a great
opportunity to you know do something
that was both cinematically satisfying
for myself so I could follow a real
story as its unfolding which is the
style of filmmaking I prefer but also it
allowed me to move away from just
telling the story of the facts of the
genocide which a more historical
approach would would allow me to do or
would only allow me to do and instead to
tell the larger story to me of the last
hundred years of denial and how denial
works the aftermath of denial so this
film was possible because of mr.
Krekorian generous donation and it was
made outside the system and that's why
it's now finally this story is out there
right the promise was made outside the
studio system Kerkorian wanted a film
about the Armenian Genocide to be made
the project was greenlit and developed
while he was still alive then he passed
but the money was in place to make the
promise and so even though there's you
know it feels like a Hollywood movie and
many people in Hollywood worked on it
it's not a product of the studio system
which allowed it to be made and so the
fact that a big-budget indie film on
this subject on the subject of the
Armenian Genocide was being made allowed
me to come in as a documentarian and
tell the larger story not just of the
genocide but also the story of denial
how denial works even even subtle forms
of denial you know the US State
Department saying hey it's in our
interest
don't make that movie which to me is
morally repugnant you know I mean we
give lots of money to Turkey as you know
enter in the form of aid do they you
know do we really think that by making
by allowing our artist to have freedom
of expression allowing Studios to make
whatever movie they want to make will
interfere with why we have an alliance
with Turkey and why we have an alliance
with Turkey in part is their strategic
importance you know they're they're
literally their strategic location below
Russia and above the Middle East has
been an important factor in all of our
first during the Cold War being able to
use their have military bases there so
that we can have listening posts so we
can have bombing missions into the
Middle East during the Iraq war so we
want to keep this Ally happy which I
don't disagree with but at what moral
price when it goes so far as to not
acknowledge a genocide what's the secret
to finding truth when making a
documentary I mean is there anything
that you say or do that helps you find
it we could spend hours and hours and
talk about truth in documentaries
because I look I'm I'm a firm believer
that all documentary filmmaking all
media is inherently subjective you shoot
hundreds of hours of footage only a
couple of hours ends up in your final
film there are days you're not there to
cover a story you have you choose a
camera angle every camera angle
communicates a different emotion
potentially you make thousands of
editorial decisions so what's guided me
is that I am NOT looking for the capital
truth capital T truth of a situation
because I think truth is very elusive
and subjective depending on from what
point of view you're looking at it from
what I look for in my films is an
emotional truthfulness an emotional
truth of this about the human condition
or
subject that you're looking at you know
in Paradise Lost it becomes clear these
guys were railroaded but a different
filmmaker would have possibly made a
different film so I think I think
filmmakers who think that they're
presenting the absolute truth about a
particular subject
I have potentially you know certain
certain kinds of films straightforward
history you know I think it's more you
know hitting the truth whatever that
means is possible but when I'm looking
for are the emotional truthfulness of a
situation you know the truth rises to
the top if you allow both sides to have
their say treat the audience like a jury
and not pound a specific message over
people's heads it has always been the
method that I've preferred even in this
film even though it's a film about
denial and genocide there's a section of
the film in which those who don't
believe the genocide took place they're
given a chance to air their views and we
allow the audience you know we allow the
audience to make up their own minds
about it so to me that's what I mean by
emotional truthfulness you air you air
all sides of an issue don't pound a
message over the viewers head and you
let the truth rise to the top in crude
you know some people were surprised that
I allowed the executives from Chevron to
give it you know to be interviewed and
to present their point of view about the
case but I think I trust the audience to
come to the right conclusion about the
emotional truthfulness of the situation
and sometimes the emotional truthfulness
of a situation is not necessarily what
you think the film is about you know for
example in crude the indigenous rain
forest dwellers of Ecuador and their
American lawyers were you know making a
case and suing Chevron for creating this
cancer deaths on the size of Rhode
Island through bad drilling practices
Chevron was claiming that that's not the
case
and the pollution that's there is the
responsibility of the state oil company
some people may think that I was making
a film about the absolute truth of that
situation for me the absolute truth of
the situation the the emotional truth of
the situation that I was trying to talk
about is that we are destroying the
rainforest that the people who you know
most deserve to be treated well were
being treated horribly and that there
was a whole other set of reasons I was
making that film to bring justice to
these people so sometimes the subjective
truth of a situation is not always what
the filmmaker is necessarily trying to
you know present at least that's how I
look at it you've covered so many niches
from Metallica and therapy the West
Memphis Three Tony Robbins whitey bulger
at this stage of your career how do you
know when you want to invest time and
money into a story what is it about a
story that you know ok this is something
I want to commit several years and maybe
even a lifetime yeah to dealing with you
know I've been lucky enough to really
cover a wide range of material and to
make quite a few films somehow they keep
letting me do it and the strange thing
is that you know sometimes you know
instead of me choosing the subject the
subject kind of chooses me at a period
in my life where I feel like you know
there's something I need to learn you
know for Tony Robbins I was open to that
kind of thinking for the first time in
my life and it's a very positive film
because Tony had a very positive impact
on my life and I wanted to share that
with other people you know some people
looked at that film and we're waiting
for the third act shoe to drop where I
rip him to shreds and show why what he's
doing is a bad thing but that wasn't my
intention with Metallica there was a
whole other set of reasons in my life
why that film
came to me so and when I look back in
some ways a lot a lot of the times the
the subject that I need to learn about
at that moment seems to be my guiding
principle as odd as that sounds but it's
not just a passive thing either
obviously I choose the films that I want
to make and generally I look for
opportunities where by focusing on the
plight of a particular individual it
shines a light on a larger aspect of the
human condition and you know I think
film is an incredible medium for social
change I mean I've had the good fortune
and where much of my work has had a
direct impact on a case or a situation
and so I'm always you know if if I can
you know whether it's my you know I just
finished a couple of recent television
series one for spike about it's called
gone The Forgotten women Ohio where the
mothers of these dead and missing
prostitutes were feeling like nobody
cared about their situation nobody cared
about solving the crimes of these went
against these women because they were
prostitutes and drug abusers and I felt
like look everyone deserves justice
regardless of your lifestyle and so I
looked into that case and was compelled
to kind of try to help and provide some
answers so I always look first and and I
felt I could actually make a difference
you know some stories are presented to
me where I feel like I can't get the
access or whatever but you know it's
it's a it's a strange group of criteria
that make me feel like this is the right
thing you know and then at the most
basic level are these is this a
situation or are these people that I
want to spend two two and a half years
with because that's that's the arc of of
a film excuse me
and even if it's an ugly story that's
you know whether it's a pleasant story
or an ugly story that's not
the deciding factor of do I want to
spend two two and a half years it's who
are these people can I make an impact
can I be successful in in in my
filmmaking mission and those are kind of
the factors as to whether or not you
want to spend two and a half years of
your life doing something so what was
the documentary that made you want to be
a documentary filmmaker interesting a
number of films I think really had an
impact on me while deciding to be a
filmmaker you know I think the film that
most impacted me was 2d cut Follies by
frederick wiseman an unfiltered view
into this mental institution and the
kind of access that today is almost well
access and a complete lack of awareness
amongst people that they were being
filmed which I think we achieved in
brother's keeper I think the people and
brother's keeper the brothers didn't
really understand what a film was meant
and so we got really unfiltered reality
and that's what I felt in 2d cut Follies
it's just this incredible immersion into
a world that you may not think you want
to go but by going into that world and
taking that journey that the film offers
it drops you on the other side as it as
a changed person because it's it makes
you think so deeply about your own life
and life in general and to me that's the
mission of a documentary you want to
take somebody into a world that they may
not even think they want to go or care
to go take them on an intellectual and
emotional journey and when the film is
over you have had like some profound
moments of reflection that really deeply
affect your life and that's how I felt
when I saw - to cut Follies the other
film that was incredibly influential to
me was Thin Blue Line I was not a
filmmaker yet and seeing thin blue line
at a cinema
with the Miramax logo thinking wow this
is a this is a documentary made for the
theatrical audience that really spoke
deeply to me because I loved movies I
loved the theatrical experience but that
was the film that made me think okay I
want to make movies documentary movies
in a cinema you know for the cinema for
a theatrical audience which of course
these days that's harder and harder to
come by and we can talk about the impact
of streaming and all that but you know
brother's keeper was an attempt to make
a film for theatrical audiences at a
time that the theatrical documentary was
quite a rare breed and so I think thin
blue line really you know city cut
Follies made me realize what I wanted to
do in film and thin blue line kind of
made me feel like the venue for this
kind of film making is the theatrical
setting and of course you know the fact
that thin blue line led to the release
of somebody wrongfully convicted also
was deeply inspiring for what I ended up
doing with you know my films so those
are two there are many others John
Cassavetes actually I would say isn't
even bigger influence because I love
what Cassavetes you know Cassavetes did
with scripted material what I feel we do
with unscripted material you know kind
of the inverse like just you know
Cassavetes would make you feel like
you're watching something incredibly
authentic but it's a movie and I feel
like what we attempt to do with the
style of documentary making is to tell a
very truthful story but to do it in a
cinematic way that feels like a piece of
cinema
you